My kids have never had the opportunity to eat popular
kid marketed foods
because my food standards are really high
and I prioritize health over convenience.
Nevertheless,
they can still enjoy these fun foods quite easily
with a little bit of creativity and desire.
Their friends at school eat goldfish at snack time
and rather than feel like they're missing out,
I decided to make some for my kids.
A snack boxes to.
The homemade version is so much more delicious
like a savory shortbread.
These are made with all purpose eincorn flour
which gives them a lighter feel
than if using freshly milled
100% whole grain flour.
Eincorn is ideal for kids with gluten sensitivity
as it doesn't upset the tummy.
This all purpose flour contains 85% of the brand
in this freshly milled order.
So it's not like the other white flowers
that have been sitting on the grocery shops for months
and stripped up their nutrients.
This five ingredient
homemade goldfish is free of soybean oil
and glyphosate sprayed wheat,
so this is a definite win.
One thing I forgot to add in
was ground turmeric for yellow color,
which I'll be sure to do next time
so that we can have a perfect goldfish dupe.